[Music]
it's a pleasure to be here it next with
all of you I'm project them I'm a
product manager in cloud networking
thanks for being here my name is Mike
Columbus I manage a specialist team of
networking professionals that help
customers like yourselves on their
journey to Google cloud so what does it
really take to build and manage services
in today's world the world is hybrid the
world is multi cloud customers have
hybrid and multi cloud deployments
because they want higher availability
they want to mix and match the best of
great solutions from each of the clouds
or because they cannot move all of their
services to cloud now there's no doubt
that hybrid and multi cloud deployments
are here to stay but one of the
questions we hear all the time from
customers is how can we go and manage
these deployments seamlessly without all
of the toil one of the big trends that
we see is the move from monoliths to
micro services and they're moving to
them for agility and then also for
manageability but imagine you had a
monolith you took it you chopped it up
into 120 microservices how are you going
to deploy secure Connect manage these
micro services what you really need is a
way to create new services uniformly you
also need services management
infrastructure which you obviously don't
want to create build or manage and you
need security resiliency and
observability for your services and that
is where service mesh comes in now
service mesh is a very powerful
abstraction that's becoming increasingly
popular to deliver micro services and
also for multi cloud applications so
think a few years back like what exactly
serviced mesh think of you know boxes
appliance is a few years back you do all
of these complex network appliances what
did you do to them they're keep
software-defined networking and you took
this complex bot box you disaggregated
it you created a very simple forwarding
plane
and you moved all of the complexity up
to the control plane and then these
simple data planes were controlled by
that control plane think of service mesh
is exactly Sdn for services now what are
you doing here you're taking a complex
application you're removing all of the
networking code from it you're putting a
load of it as a sidecar proxy and then
you need something to go manage all of
these sidecar proxies and that is where
the control plane of the service mesh
comes into the picture so let's take a
closer look at the service mesh what is
a mesh essentially a mesh abstracts away
the network from your application so
your individual services or the apps you
write don't necessary have to be aware
of the network they only know about
their local sidecar proxy now each proxy
obviously has to be configured and
managed and so that's where the service
mesh control plane comes in it makes all
of these distributed proxies and
configures them into something larger
and then you get visibility you get
resiliency you get traffic control
security and observability so that is
actually the value out of your service
mesh think of the data plane we talked
about a sidecar proxy one of the most
popular sidecar proxies is envoy it was
built at lift it is a very high
performance proxy it has skins
eventually consistent service discovery
and the reason we like is its extensible
and it has a protocol called XDS v2
which it uses between the control plane
and the proxy and so you could use any
other proxy that suppose this XDS
protocol and therefore you can use envoy
that is teo provides you can use envoy
that is your own or you could use
another proxy that is compliant with the
60s video protocol so it's fairly
it doesn't lock you in into any specific
proxy or even any specific control plane
so the biggest benefit of service mesh
is that a decouples development from
operations and so as a developer you
don't need to worry about writing and
maintaining policies and the networking
code inside your application at all one
of the really nice things about service
mesh is it doesn't make any assumptions
now it doesn't make assumptions whether
your service is in cloud
on Prem it doesn't make assumptions
about whether your service is a VM based
service a container based service so it
assumes things are heterogeneous it
assumes they are spread out and that is
what it affords you in that it gives you
this unifying abstraction to create
services and obviously manage them at
scale so one of the most popular service
mesh technologies which is an
open-source is this tier
what is this tier it's essentially
giving you three main things one is
advanced networking capabilities and
routing capabilities but without you
having to write that code enhance
security and it is also giving you a lot
of observability into what is happening
as your summary services communicate
with each other let's take a closer look
at this tier now look at the data plane
that is where you have your service
sitting next to it is a sidecar proxy
and then on the top is the control plane
so it has three main pieces pilot mixer
and then there's the sto security bit
pilots going to give envoys the
configuration it's going to do the load
balancing and then it's also going to do
service discovery what you have on the
security side is things such as mutual
TLS between your services and then
observability lets you map out all of
your services along with the traffic
flow and then other things that are
happening is your services communicate
with each other now one of the other
things that you will also need for your
service mesh is you need something that
guards your entry point and that is your
sto gateway or your ingress and now this
is where you would essentially deploy
something like a global load balancer in
front the reason is that you need the
DDoS defense you would put your sto gate
or your instances behind and then that
becomes your entry point to the mesh so
if you think of it you've taken all of
the traffic routing all of the
customization all of the programmability
right to the edge of your service mesh
with this one one of the key pieces of
is your spy --let this is the one that
goes and manages and configures all of
the Envoy proxies it is the one that
knows about all of the other envoy
instances it's the one that provides
service discovery and it also delivers
advanced traffic control now our
customer
love service mesh but they always say we
don't want to go and build these control
planes we don't want to go manage pilot
and so what did we do if you were there
in the keynote this morning we launched
traffic directors you are one of the
first few people to hear about it after
that launch our new GCP managed service
for the service mesh and what it really
does is it helps you power up service
meshes of all all types of all sizes you
get global load balancing which is huge
and we'll talk about it a little bit
more you get centralized health checking
so there is somebody that's offloading
your proxies from health checking every
other application instance there is in
your network you also get traffic driven
auto scaling so as your traffic grows
your things your services scale up and
down and then you get traffic control
capabilities like Canaries and so on
that we'll talk about a little bit more
one of the nice things as traffic
directors GCP managed which means you
get a production grade isolate GA and so
if something happens you can call our
support you don't have to worry about it
yourself so if you look at this you see
traffic directly in the control plane
it's managing the sidecar proxies one of
the nice things about traffic director
is it works out of the box for VMs and
containers so if you look at the service
here imagine that your front-end service
is essentially self-managed daugher your
shopping cart service is deployed in VMs
because you possibly had that service
from before and then your payment
service could be again an VMs or it
could be a GK a service and so what this
means is you have a unified way to do
traffic management for any type of
service without having to have a
separate implementation or a solution
for each one of these types now a lot of
you here are likely our global load
balancing customers and one of the
questions we would always get is when
are you bringing global load balancing
to micro services that are internal not
external facing and that is where
traffic director is going to bring
global load balancing to your internal
micro-services and to the service mesh
and to take a closer look at it I'd like
to invite Mike to give you a deep dive
into the global load balancing as
thanks for jacta so so in the next
section I'm going to talk about global
load balancing with traffic director and
also have the pleasure of doing a few
live demos in front of my new friends
here so no pressure there it and then
finally we'll take a deeper look at like
what happened under the covers when I
ran these demos we're gonna take a few
different views into the environment so
it should be fun but before we get to
that I think it's really important to
understand the data model that traffic
director uses so has I'm sure a lot of
folks the audience have deployed a load
balancer on Google cloud platform this
data model should not look it should
look similar right so the first thing
that you need is a global forwarding
rule this consists of an IP a port and a
protocol and what's a little bit
different about this global forwarding
rule is that the IP only has
significance to the services when they
try to talk to other services inside of
the mesh the IP can really be anything
right and I'll get into a little bit
more about how that works later so think
of it this way for every service inside
the mesh that needs a unique fit you're
gonna need a global forwarding rule for
that service global forwarding rules
point to target HTTP proxies a good way
to think about this is these are the
actual service proxies inside of your
mesh right so this is really powerful
these proxies are the ones that are
getting traffic redirected to it in
creating the policy that's distributed
throughout the mesh so within a target
HTTP proxy think of this is is really
just a config pointer in in this target
HTTP proxy will configure a URL map the
URL map has been enhanced to allow for
things like rule matches and rule
actions right so really powerful things
that provide granular traffic routing
policies on top of just looking at the
host of URL paths as part of the l7 mesh
the URL map points to your back-end
service this
and services global and this is where
you're gonna configure things like
health checking along with some
enhancements that are part of this
launch which are traffic policies that
projector will cover later in each
back-end service you can configure your
backends these can consist of managed
instance groups for VMs or network
endpoint groups for containers or gke so
what's really cool about the solution is
you don't have to be running containers
or kubernetes to take advantage of this
as long as you can install a service
proxy on your VM or on your pod or on
your container you can leverage a lot of
the power that comes from this at this
platform all right so here we can see a
high-level view of the traffic director
service mesh we've shown this a few
times it's it's it's also what maps to
our demo so it has it's pretty
significant here so what we have here is
in a web service that's behind our
global load balancer so we have two
back-end management instance groups they
happen to be running docker containers
but they're managed instance groups of
VMs deployed in US Central and Asia
Southeast so depending on where that
client hits our edge the our front end
network is going to route them to the
optimal healthy back end with available
capacity from there we have a cart
service and a payment service that is
mirrored in each region so what's really
cool about traffic director is we have a
global view of available service
endpoints and our infrastructure keeps a
map of what what is the RTT between
these endpoints and the default policy
is that we're always going to route
traffic to the healthiest endpoint with
available serving capacity so we'll
start with the closest zone and failover
to regions and redirect traffic
accordingly now I want to take a minute
just to contrast this architecture with
how you might do this in a traditional
three-tier app right you're gonna have
some sort of middle edge proxy load
balancer and you're gonna configure it
on a hop by hop basis with traffic
director think of it as embedding a
client-side load balancer at every
service and the policy is also embedded
as a sidecar directly on that service so
once you know traffic gets directed to
the proxy the proxy makes a really
intelligent routing decision
or the next end point and that's a
direct communication without having to
funnel traffic through something else to
make a load-balancing decision so here
we can see the view of Maya and
California I guess I'm Maya today but
I'll be running the demo here from the
Moscone Center so under normal
circumstances I'm going to hit that the
global load balancer that's going to
direct me to the web front-end the web
front-end is gonna call the cart service
and then that's going to call the
payment service we're going to buy a lot
of things today but under normal
circumstances default policy it's going
to wrote me as such through US central
for Schenn in Singapore and I have a
client that's going to emulate an
Singapore client I'm going to be routed
through the US I'm sorry the Asia
Southeast one web service and then
throughout the the mesh in that in that
region
so what we're also going to do and this
animation shows this is that we're gonna
fail the US central one cart service and
observe the behavior so because traffic
director has global view and tries to
route things optimally once the US
central one service fails you're gonna
see that we get almost instantaneously
directed to the healthy capacity in Asia
Southeast one and then we'll fail the
server back and we'll take a look at
this so if we can shipped switch to the
podium very good
so here you can see we have a traffic
director demo project this is where the
environments contained and I want to
show a few things so I can prove to you
that this is a real environment so the
first thing I want to look at is our
instance groups so we have a few the
first you can see is that we have two
web backends these are backends behind
the global load balancer this is our web
service and we have two managed instance
groups of one instance I don't recommend
doing a management since group of one
instance but I guess it allows us to be
fairly frugal for this demo environment
next I'll call out the cart service
which is these this managed instance
group here so that's running as the
managed instance group with with envoy
and installed on each innocents atscript
VM finally we have our payment service
this is running on container engine or
gke so we have a deployment which is our
v1 and later in this presentation will
show a traffic splitting Canary style
release but that's running as on gke and
we can jump over into our kubernetes
engine and we can take a look at these
workloads or these deployments
now these manifests have an annotation
on them that says use network endpoint
group so if you're not familiar with any
way describe this a little bit earlier
but if you're not familiar with what
Network endpoint groups are I think of
it as a port an IP pair that allows us
to directly target the container rather
than the node and why this is important
is if you're familiar with with how
kubernetes works there's something
called the cube proxy that's almost like
a second hop load balancer that would
then select a pod behind that service
this allows us to directly target the
pods themselves and there's a controller
that gets spun up so as pods are scaled
up or down or you know they go away or
new services are attached that is going
to program the endpoint awareness for a
traffic director to know where to send
traffic so a little bit more on that
later
and finally Before we jump in and start
buying things we have our network
services we have traffic director in the
UI so here you can see that we have our
cart and our payment back-end services
and they each think they're healthy but
they each have a back-end and in Asia in
u.s. Central right so so that's the
environment so what I'll do first is
this is a local client this is me Mike
in California and you can see that this
front-end is served by US central one
right so the global load balancer
directed us to the web service in u.s.
central one which is good the other
thing you might note is that this you
know domain is is secured just a little
side note this is using a Google Cloud
manage cert on our global load balancer
it's also using identity where proxy so
if you're trying to get to the site
like while I trust everyone here I can't
have you stopping the services so so
we're just gonna leave it at that so you
know normal normal connection here I'm
on the web front end let's say we want
to buy $300 popsicle kinda crazy
we'll add this to our cart and you can
see now this changed to say this is the
cart service in US central and then
we'll confirm confirm the purchase and
you know we can enter our shipping
information but it's interesting I don't
see any shipping price being calculated
here wouldn't it be cool if we had that
so it's a little bit of a tease our v2
of payments the next view we'll take
let's buy something as Schenn in in
Singapore so you can see that Chen was
directed I can refresh this so you don't
think I'm so so shen was directed to
Asia Southeast region being a Singapore
client and get some green slip-ons and
we're directed to the cart service in
Asia Southeast won and as you might
guess also the payment service and it's
a southeast one but what would happen if
we failed service so what I'm gonna do
is stop the cart service in US central
one so this is this is not actually like
turning down the VM it's a management
group of one but we're basically telling
the service to now return 500 errors
that are gonna fail the health checks so
now let's see what happens so let's go
back to our this is me connecting
locally so go to TDD Supino are calm all
right
so we're still going to the web
front-end this is again the global load
balancer directing us to the web let's
buy a clock and we'll add it to our cart
and you'll notice this is now served by
asia southeast so traffic director had
no local capacity
it's a managed instance group of one if
it had something in another zone it
would have used that but we want to make
this more dramatic and fail across
region so we did that in when we confirm
the purchase it's it stays in easy
because the payment service is the
closest next hop or end point for the
cart service so the final thing we'll do
here is let's start our cart service
back up this will now allow the cart
service to pass the health check and
hopefully you know we see everything
stick in us central so let's buy
something else
anyone have any preferences goldfish
bowl what was it radio I heard radio
first where's the radio oh yeah it's a
bargain at 300 bucks all right we'll add
this to our cart
and you know the car the card I brush by
but it was us central and we stuck on
the US central for the payment service
so if we can switch back to the slides I
just want to cover what happened there
oh cool
so endpoint awareness how does traffic
director and associated you know these
service proxies know where to go the way
this works for vm's is we have something
called backend manager back-end manager
is informing traffic director of
endpoint awareness and then that's
getting sent to the relevant service
proxies so they know where everything
lives right I describe this a little bit
for for firkin for kubernetes and energy
ke the network endpoint Group controller
is talking to traffic director as an
annotation as part of the deployment
manifest and that's how we get endpoint
awareness and we know where the pods are
so what happened when something failed
when I failed that the service the US
central one cart service
we're health checking our endpoints as a
service right which is which is very
powerful and then once the shopping cart
service went down again traffic director
removed the within the service mesh that
you know path the shopping cart endpoint
for US central for that path right so
we're kind of creating this like else of
an overlay Network here which is really
cool so from the data plane what
happened again this is client-side
decision so I'm going to show this from
the context of I came in from the global
load balancer terminated on the web
service in US central one and via the
control plan we know that that end point
the next you know the healthiest end
point the cart service neo central one
was unhealthy so we're gonna look at
this from the perspective of the web
service so the way this works we have
our VM here we have our proxy installed
and in that's you know got a persistent
connection to traffic director and the
proxy is listening on port 15,000 won on
the loop on the localhost and then the
the web service is bound to on port 80
for the actual IP address of the VM so
the web service wants to talk to the
cart service doesn't know that any
services down it just has a VIP this is
again the global forwarding rule so the
app I'm sorry the the app the web
service requests the cart service which
is this VIP that I configured and then
it there's IP tables rules that
configures netfilter to say anything you
know either everything that goes
outbound or specific to the VIPs in my
service gets redirected as part of the
output chain to the service proxy and
again the service proxy has the
configuration it intercepts the request
and now I can apply the policy that was
configured as part of traffic director
which targets the endpoint right so it
knows all the health visits it's
targeting the healthiest endpoint which
actually sends that traffic over our
global V PC to to a Giselle this one
endpoint so I'll hand it back to
projector thank you Mike so now I wonder
so now a quick warning we're gonna take
you through a whirlwind of different
features we obviously won't have enough
time to spend on each of them but we
wanted you to know about them and then
feel free to get hold of us after the
talk
so one of the most interesting features
that traffic director provides is
traffic control if many of you have used
envoy you've already used these features
so let's take a quick look the biggest
thing about you know like way before you
had to actually go architect all of
these traffic control capabilities into
either your application or some system
here you get all of that without doing
anything to your application so what if
you think of how you configure this
think that there are two buckets one is
the routing rules and one is the traffic
policies routing rules look at that the
client traffic that's coming in and then
they figure out where to send it and
what to do with it the traffic policies
are more about your service that's being
accessed or being connected to and so
what does that service 1 that's what you
express through traffic policies - yep
so let's go a little bit deeper into the
routing rules again reminding you about
the data model that Mike showed which is
you have the URL map that's where your
routing rules reside and then you have
this notion of a back-end service in GCP
and that's where your traffic policies
reside because they go and apply to your
back-end service so what kind of things
would you want to do one of the things
that you'd want to do is essentially
imagine you have a version a running of
your service and you decided to roll out
2.0 and staging and you want to actually
split traffic because you want to see
how the other new version is doing
that's what you can seamlessly do with
traffic director and the Envoy with what
we call traffic splitting so you simply
put weights like you see here and it'll
split the traffic another interesting
thing you could do is traffic steering
so imagine that in here you're looking
at certain characteristics of your
incoming traffic and saying if the user
agent is Android send it to the back-end
service that's actually dealing with
Android stuff and if the user agent is
iPhone send it to the back-end instances
in the service that's dealing with the
iPhone stuff so and you can do very rich
matches you can also take a bunch of
actions or traffic splitting redirects
or you can do real URL rewrites and then
several other things as well
another very interesting thing is fault
injection so as you write out your
service you do want to test the
resiliency of your service and you want
to test it against things like delays
aborts and so on and so it's a part of
the fault injection what happens here is
that the client when it sends a request
to the backend service there's a delay
that can be introduced by the traffic
director say on a percentage of your
requests that are getting sent to the
backend service and you can also send a
certain percentage of your request going
there to be aborted so in this way you
can actually test the resiliency of your
app without really building out any of
this infrastructure yourself this is one
of my personal favorite features which
is mirroring so what you can do here is
imagine you have your main app you can
create a shadow app and then as the real
traffic comes to your main app you can
shadow all over all of that traffic to
your shadow app so and then the shadow
app treats this as fire-and-forget which
means it gets the response but it's not
going to respond back to it so it's a
very nice way to actually go and test
out a bunch of things such as binaries
with production traffic or you can debug
errors that are happening in production
using the shadow debug service so this
is I really love this feature personally
now let's come to the second part of it
and they are actually several other
features that I didn't cover in the
routing rules but coming to traffic
policies now this is the backend service
telling the client here is how I'd like
you to behave or here is how the traffic
should be load balanced across my
instances and so it's from the
perspective of a back-end service so
each of these policies are obviously
specified for a back-end service now
let's do let's take an example of one
such policy which is load balancing so
Mike show you the global load balancing
so initially he showed the global load
balancing which traffic director and our
global systems used to figure out which
is the zone of the region to send your
traffic to now once it lands there you
will have multiple instances there and
so that's when the second tier of your
load balancing kicks in and then it
figures out which is the best or the
optimal instance to use for your traffic
so you can see one in two and that's
what it is referring to in
second stage essentially you have
several different lb algorithms that you
can turn on so things like round-robin
least request ring ash random and
several others as well and you can do a
non session affinity if that's important
to your app so circuit breakers how many
of you here are familiar with circuit
braking I think it is a topic we could
all talk about for an entire day but my
aha moment about circuit braking came
when I was talking to Georgie who's a
distinguished engineer at Walmart and he
said there are several circuit braking
solutions that exist but one of the
really nice things about envoy and
traffic direct in this solution is that
it's from the perspective of a back-end
service so the backend service will say
I can accept a max of five connections
from your client and so when the client
tries to send more than that the proxy
on the client just throttles itself so
it's like back pressure to the client
but it's from the perspective of a
back-end service and this is this part
was what was missing in several of the
other solutions that existed so it is
you had to guess what the back in
service wanted from a client's
perspective so this is the thing that is
actually huge about circuit braking you
can also do things like outlier
detection and then you can eject out the
instances that actually don't conform to
whatever policy it is that you want for
your back-end service so with that I
want you to invite Mike again to give
you we just pick one of the features
which is traffic splitting it is one of
our very popular features and give you a
closer look at it all right thanks
protector so we get to buy more things
so as part of this demo you know we
weren't calculating shipping costs
before we want to deploy a version two
of our payments that does charge for
shipping so if we can switch back to the
podium oh thanks
so while projector was speaking I I did
a few things and I want to talk through
what I did so I am in our cloud shell
code enter code code editor which is
super helpful and I have a few shell
scripts that I ran the first was
actually creating the deployment for
version two of the payment service so I
just deployed that and that's running in
in gke the next thing I did was I added
the this little smaller
I created the back-end service for our
new delivery v2 version of our
deployment I created a health check for
it and I you know specified the flag
that made it global the next thing I did
was I grabbed the network endpoint group
name for each cluster remember it was US
Central and Asia South one southeast one
and I added that as a back-end to the
backend service I just created so that
was creating kind of the traffic
director constructs and then the final
thing I did was update the URL map to
split the traffic 5050 across the two
back-end services and what that did was
actually deploy the Shamu file which I
called canary so I have a really simple
path matcher and it's basically takes
the default service and splits it so you
can see I have waited back-end services
and I give a weight of 50 or 50 percent
to the back-end service that this was
the v1 version and this is the version
two and I might as well show it we and
then in in kubernetes engine you can see
if I go into the workloads each cluster
now has the non-delivery version and
then they the delivery version every -
so let's buy something let's see what
we're gonna buy now let's buy a
surfboard it's almost summer so what
I'll do is now when I add this to the
cart again we're served by US central
cart and you can see now I have delivery
charge right and this is this is gonna
be fairly variable if i refresh this
page a few times you can see it's about
half well as you'd expect it's about
half the time we have the shipping cost
so basically what's happening is the
client-side proxy when the cart service
talks to
the dilute the the payment service half
the time it's choosing the the delivery
deployment half the time it isn't and I
could you know wait this accordingly so
just one example of kind of how this
works but but pretty powerful and you
might say well I haven't put in my my
address how does it know that delivery
cost it's a demo maybe that'll be free
right so thank you all hand it back over
to projector how can we get the slides
so we spoke about traffic director and
we spoke about the citecar envoy we
actually have another interesting
product called l7 I'll be and I'll talk
a little bit more about it if you think
of a lot of you you may be using load
balancers and what you're saying is just
give me a simple l7 load balancer that
brings in all of the capabilities of
envoy but I don't want to deal with
traffic director and I don't want to
deal with envoy and because all you care
about is essentially a load balancer
that's for your internal services that
brings in all of these capabilities and
that is what l7i lb gives you so think
of you've got a front-end and then
you've got your shopping cart and you've
got your payments and you simply put the
l7 il be like a fridge just like any
middle proxy load balancer and then you
load balance your instances behind
you're essentially not injecting any
proxies on your back-end instances the
other side of it is there's another set
of you who are you have your existing
deployments and you want to bring in all
of this service mesh and all of these
modern paradigms into your existing
ground field and that is the other use
case of l7i lb so it helps you bring
service mesh to your brownfield without
disruption so let's take a look imagine
that you've got two services the
front-end and the shopping cart you were
able to use or you were able to put in
or the Envoy proxies you configure
traffic director for it now you have
this really ancient payment service and
there is no way you can go and inject a
proxy in there so what do you do but you
do want to bring in all the
modernization and the capabilities that
you would get with envoy and so what
you're doing there is essentially you
bring in the l7 I'll be because it lets
you have all of the capabilities but
without having to go and inject anything
in your back-end
instances so it's a really good way to
start migrating your services towards
these modern paradigms and this is what
it looks like under the hood so what we
did for you is we abstracted our traffic
director and we abstracted out the pool
of the managed middle proxy pool of
envoys and it looks like any other
internal load balancer to you and you
simply configure it that way so it's as
simple as what you see you saw in the
previous slide but then this is what is
under the hood so we do believe this is
a very good way for you to get started
with the service mesh especially in your
brownfield deployments or if you're just
looking for that next level of load
balancing compared to what you have to
do so we spoke about a bunch of features
but honestly that's just the start we
have several exciting features on the
roadmap some of these we just started
working on some of these will come
sometime this year or next but one of
the first important things we will do an
integration with is all of the security
features that you get with SEO which is
things like M TLS are back and so on
the second big integration we will do is
with a number of observability solutions
and we will have more than one so you
can and you can even today you can
actually go and integrate your own like
if you're using for instance Apache sky
walking or any of the other tools you
can go integrate those as well the third
important thing is that we always get
asked so traffic director is amazing for
services that are in GCP what do we do
with our services that are sitting on
frame and so that is where we do want to
support hybrid and multi cloud with
traffic director so your instances stay
wherever they are today but then you use
traffic director to go and manage them
then the fourth thing is a lot of you
use Sto and so if you're using pilot
traffic director is a very good fit for
a fully managed service so which means
we have to support is Toa API so you can
actually take the pilot and swap it out
with traffic director so that is the
whole integration story into estion and
thoughts that you will hear more about
in the coming year one of the most
interesting and areas of innovation is
Federation this is probably the part
we've just started singing but there are
other service mesh control planes out
there some are legacy some are
different implementations but there
needs to be a way to federate these and
you will hear us talking a lot more
about Federation in the coming months or
coming year so hybrid I pointed out this
is what it looks like you've got traffic
director you've got your instances on
Prem and then you've got the same
traffic director managing instances that
are in GCP so that's a hybrid story this
is what the Istrian anthos integration
looks like so you can see that there's a
layer of sto api's that you can use for
configuration and obviously that should
work whether your instances are in GCP
or on prem and then the key benefit of
this is you will get global load
balancing for all of your services you
will get a highly managed control plane
which you don't have to worry about
managing even for your services on Prem
and one of the nice things again is that
we use the XTS v2 API is for
communicating between the control plane
and the data plane what that means is
you're not locked in into traffic
director so you can swap it out back for
pilot or another implementation as long
as it uses the open ex DSP to api's so
this is what Federation could look like
this is probably a place will innovate
with with the community as well and so
you will hear a more about more about it
in terms of sto and several other
communities that we are a part of but
what is the need for Federation like
what is driving the need for us to go
look at this first thing is there are
lot of implementations where you want a
flat mesh so you want seamless melding
of what's on Prem and in GCP the second
one is if you have traffic director
control things that are on Prem you
should assume that the connectivity
between on frame and GCP will fail and
so you need a backup control plane so
there's a whole aspect of resiliency
there the third one is sometimes you
want to have any control collaboration
because entity a might be a totally
different set up from Watson GCP and you
want to federate state like things like
config identity but in a very controlled
manner and so you need proper primitives
interfaces and abstractions to make that
happen and then the last one is people
are going to have variety of control
planes and as we introduce traffic
director for instance we don't expect
people to throw away all of their
control planes at once because they want
to test it out and then they're slowly
going to introduce
into a variety of their deployments and
so we do assume that the world will have
multiple the service mesh control planes
and we have to figure out a way to
operate in that environment and then
help you move your services over to
traffic director or if you choose to
keep the other ones that do so what do
we have
overall in GCP like we spoke about a
bunch of things today give you a
whirlwind tour of the traffic director
and l7i lb capabilities so let's again
go back to your starting point if you
are a cloud load balancing users you can
think of traffic director as bringing in
envoy and this is this could be in the
form of just a managed middle proxy so
you use it like any other load balancer
so it's just like an l 7i lb that's
there for your services but with the
primitives and the modern traffic
control capabilities that you get with
one voice and with this to you then if
you're one step ahead in your
modernization phase or if you have new
apps that you want to bring in there
that's when you would use traffic
director with just like with a
traditional service mesh where you've
got the envoys a sidecar proxy and then
the main thing is that in both of these
cases you don't really have to worry
about managing the control plane because
you actually want to worry about your
apps in your business the last thing any
of you here want to do is go manage
these control planes so that is what
it's letting you do in here one of the
nice things is that this works out of
the box for kubernetes like I mentioned
before self manage kubernetes GK docker
VMs because one of the things I hear
very frequently is service mesh is for
containers actually that is not true at
all because if you took a monolith and
you chopped it up because if you
containerize a monolith you're not going
to get any benefits so if you're taking
a monolith and chopping it up the first
thing you're actually going to need a
services management before you even even
containerize so one of the
misconceptions that we want to remove
and also make it true what traffic
director is that service mesh is for VMs
services and for containers it is for
Greenfield and it is for brownfield it
is for enterprises cloud natives it is
an abstraction that should work across
the board and then of course we have GR
pieces another project in which Google
is
involved that is an excellent interface
if you have apps that support G RPC and
then most of our testing for all of
traffic director has been with envoy we
really like the envoy proxy because we
believe it delivers almost like a
universal data plane but any other proxy
that supports X Dias can be brought in
there is nothing that locks you in
either into traffic director or into
envoy you can bring your own envoy as
well the second part of it is so you're
coming now from the service mesh or a
service management angle and so that is
where if you see here this is the this
is like when you think about anthos or
you think about GK on Prem all you think
about traffic director R is to what it's
really helping you do is to deliver
hybrid multi cloud services at scale
seamlessly without toil and so this is a
portfolio of products that's going to
help you do that imagine that you added
a few more to it so and as we integrate
with an thousand sto like it'll be much
more easier for you to migrate from any
of the things you're using current
currently to traffic director or l7 I'll
be again in here there's nothing that
necessary it's kubernetes but on Prem we
have several customers who have brought
in GK on Prem and then in Google Cloud
the fastest way to containers is using
the google kubernetes engine so this is
the last part I wanted to there is a
customer we have call Mel curry so this
example is actually inspired by them
this is how they are thinking of a
blueprint to go and modernize at their
pace without toil so in their case they
had essentially a monolith on Prem and
they what they went to is something like
this and you can notice that there's no
monolith on Prem so how did they do it
what they did is and you can just follow
the numbers what they did first is they
essentially did nothing to the monolith
they came to cloud and the monolith of
course was on Prem they came to cloud
they put a Google global load balancer
this was for DDoS defense this was for
TLS termination and so on and they put
API gateway instances behind the global
load balancer so now your traffic comes
in it seamlessly gets routed through the
API gateway to on Prem so that that is
the first set of things that they did
then they started chopping away at the
monolith what they did is they took a
chunk of the monolith and then they
created service a so you see the number
two there they had a G RPC interface for
it once they did that they actually
chopped out service be one of the things
you'll notice is every time they chopped
out anything from the monolith they
created it as a containerized service so
it was created as a containerized
service in cloud instead of doing it on
Prem once they're done la service be
they there were certain services that
could not be moved to cloud so what do
you do there so they chunked out the
service see you can see the number four
there and then they put it on Prem but
then they use GK on Prem to manage it
because they were cheek using GK which
is a google kubernetes engine in google
cloud and said GK on Prem gives you the
same primitives but to manage things on
Prem and you must have heard a lot of it
in talks in this conference as well so
now they have GK on Prem managing
service C they said now we are ready to
try out the service mesh and some of the
newer capabilities of the modern
paradigms and so they they now put envoy
proxy on service B and service fee for
this is so that the services could
communicate but now you need a control
plane because something has to go manage
those proxies and something has to make
sure that they get configuration and so
on and so forth so they first brought in
a steer because traffic director wasn't
available there and then it's do
controlled service be an sto on Prem
controlled service C now this is now
after this what will happen is now the
traffic director is available the sto
can be the pilot from Sto can be
replaced with traffic director which is
what will happen and then eventually
when we support hybrid you can see the
arrow 6 which will be able to go control
those services with the proxies on Prem
and by this point of time because you've
chopped up all of these services from
your monolith you can see that you've
totally taken away the monolith itself
so if you see here that it it's not that
people just bring in all of these
technologies one shot they have a
strategy and they bring it in in the way
that makes sense for them this is just
one strategy there's another talk we're
doing tomorrow which describes several
of these strategies but
this is a good way to bring in service
mesh and of course there's the
brownfield strategy where you could
totally use l7i lb as your starting
point so you know we our hope was that I
know we gave you a whirlwind tour of
like traffic director l7 I'll be how it
fits into the whole ecosystem but our
hope is that you know using these GCP
services and also open source services
you can manage your services seamlessly
and modernize from your starting point
at your piece and without toil thank you
[Applause]
and one last thing we have a survey we'd
really appreciate it if you filled it we
also have an online Dory so Dory's where
you can post your questions and then
Mike and I will respond to them and post
them back online so thank you thank you
for being here for guitar thanks
[Music]